[Musica]
due anni fa in questo stesso giorno ero
passeggero di un volo e mi trasportava
sulle isole canadesi di haida gwaii al
largo delle coste della columbia
britannica le isole ospitano uno degli
ecosistemi più incredibili del pianeta
una foresta pluviale temperata un nuovo
simile ai tropici ma fatto soprattutto
di conifere cedri rossi cedri gialli
abeti di sitka si spandevano
dall'interno fino alla costa dell'oceano
pacifico
la foresta con la più alta biomassa per
unità di superficie su tutta la terra
qui c'erano più foglie più tronchi più
radici che nella mazzoni
il segreto di questa foresta st
nell'acqua non soltanto nell'acqua del
pacifico che ricade sopra gli alberi
sotto forma di pioggia e nebbia ma anche
nell'acqua dei ruscelli che attraversano
la foresta e che trasportano milioni di
salmoni durante la loro risalita verso i
luoghi di riproduzione
i salmoni sono il nutrimento degli orsi
ma gli orsi sono un po schizzinosi non
mangiano tutto il salmone prendono solo
la parte più prelibata abbandonando il
resto come carcassa sul suolo della
foresta ebbene i salmoni sono così tanti
che le loro carcasse abbandonate nella
foresta pluviale temperata fertilizzano
gli alberi dando alle radici le sostanze
nutritive di cui hanno bisogno per
crescere sulle isole vivono gli aida
l'unica nazione tra quelle dei nativi
americani a non essere mai stata
sconfitta militarmente né ad aver mai
firmato alcun trattato con i
colonizzatori europei da 17.000 anni gli
aida abitano in armonia con l'oceano e
con la foresta la loro risorsa più
importante è proprio la foresta di cedro
rosso da cui ricavano cibo vestiti mezzi
di trasporto materiale per costruzione e
il legno per i totem quella particolare
forma di narrazione e memoria collettiva
che proprio gli aida hanno inventato e
distribuito poi in tutto il pacifico
settentrionale
io stesso
girando per la foresta ho visto dei
segni particolari del rapporto dell'aida
degli aida con il loro territorio
indomiti guerrieri navigatori
il segreto del loro successo erano le
canoe scafi formidabili ricavati proprio
dal legno del cedro rosso in grado di
trasportare 60 uomini per centinaia di
chilometri affrontando le onde
dell'oceano pacifico e in mezzo alla
foresta li potevo vedere ancora oggi i
tronchi lavorati a metà in forma di
canoa abbandonati forse in seguito
all'epidemia di vaiolo che nel 1880
apportata dai colonizzatori europei
sterminò il 90 per cento della
popolazione degli aida e ascoltando i
racconti delle persone che incontravo ho
imparato che ai danni della
colonizzazione e non erano che
all'inizio vedete gli aida non hanno una
cultura scritta non ce l'avevano e la
loro forma di proprietà è esclusivamente
collettiva per questo il governo
canadese ebbe gioco facile a cedere i
diritti di uso delle loro foreste alle
multinazionali del legno e della carta
nel giro di un secolo dopo la grande
epidemia di vaiolo tre quarti delle
foreste delle haida gwaii erano state
tagliate a raso e sostituite da boschi
secondari rapido accrescimento ma dalla
scarsissima biodiversità che venivano
coltivati in modo industriale per gli
aida era in gioco tutto la loro fonte di
sussistenza la loro cultura la loro
stessa sopravvivenza era a rischio
per questo nel 1985 giugno all'aja
island guidati dalle anziane ed agli
anziani
il leader della comunità misero in atto
una forma di protesta non violenta si
misero in piedi di fronte alle macchine
forestali che erano venute ad eseguire
l'ennesimo taglio e riuscirono tenerle
bloccate per ben tre mesi
oggi altre foreste nel mondo subiscono
la stessa minaccia gli incendi
dell'agosto 2019 nella foresta
amazzonica non sono che il sintomo di
una deforestazione che prosegue ormai da
cinquant'anni rimpiazzando gli alberi
con campi coltivati a soia o pascoli per
il bestiame senza sosta prosegue la
distruzione di un fondamentale serbatoio
di biodiversità
diversità e di culture dall'inizio degli
anni 80 oggi abbiamo già perso il 17 per
cento della foresta amazzonica
secondo gli scienziati se raggiungeremo
una deforestazione compresa tra il 25 e
il 40 per cento
inter amazzoni a rischia di scomparire
totalmente perché non ci saranno più
abbastanza alberi per far evaporare
l'acqua e generare così la pioggia che
alimenta tutto il sistema ma la
preoccupazione più urgente risiede forse
nel destino della foresta come serbatoio
di carbonio tutti gli alberi del mondo
con la fotosintesi assorbono il carbonio
dall'atmosfera succhiano [ __ ] de
carbonica e la chiude una chiave
nascondendola nel proprio legno o nel
suolo dove può rimanere intrappolata per
decine o centinaia di anni
un'azione di cui abbiamo un estremo
bisogno perché da oltre un secolo le
nostre emissioni di anidride carbonica
non fanno che aumentare hanno raggiunto
nel 2018 l'incredibile cifra di 37
miliardi di tonnellate soprattutto per
l'uso del petrolio degli altri
combustibili fossili
l'anidride carbonica ha il potere di
assorbire il calore della terra e
rilasciarlo lentamente nell'atmosfera
senza farlo disperdere nello spazio ed è
per questo che il pianeta si sta
scaldando se vogliamo limitare il
riscaldamento ha un grado e mezzo
abbiamo un limite possiamo emettere solo
più 420 miliardi di tonnellate di co2 in
assoluto
sembra un numero astronomico eppure
proseguendo di questo passo
raggiungeremo questo livello già tra
dieci anni per questo la soluzione più
ovvia alla crisi climatica sembrerebbe
quella di aumentare la quantità di
foreste piantando alberi ovunque sia
possibile
eppure questa è un'impresa difficile
perché occorre poter disporre dei
terreni produrre un incredibile quantità
di piantine da vivaio e soprattutto
destinare molte risorse alle cure post
impianto per permettere che questi nuovi
boschi si mantengano in buona salute
anche nei clima che verrà
un'altra soluzione è quella di usare più
legno in modo sostenibile la
selvicoltura ci insegna come ricavare
dalle foreste senza minacciare il loro
futuro se noi siamo legno al posto di
petrolio plastica o altri materiali come
il cemento e come circondarci di tante
piccole casseforti di carbonio cosa che
ci permette al tempo stesso di evitare
le emissioni necessarie a produrre ea
smaltire questi altri materiali
forse è proprio per la crisi per la
crisi climatica quindi che sentiamo
sempre più parlare di foreste in questo
tempo o forse c'è anche un altro motivo
forse le foreste ci fanno toccare con
mano i fili invisibili che ci legano
alla natura ci aprono gli occhi su un
mondo più vasto più grande di noi a cui
però apparteniamo
i nostri cuori hanno sobbalzato al
vedere la distruzione portata dalla
tempesta vai alle nostre foreste
nell'ottobre del 2018 qui vicino
si trattava solo dell'uno per cento dei
boschi eppure queste immagini
l'odore della resina il silenzio degli
uccelli c entrano dentro più di tutto
quello che sappiamo del restante 99 per
cento e forse i nostri cuori su
balzeranno di nuovo ma di gioia tra
vent'anni quando le aree bombardate dal
vento si ripopoleranno di pioppi betulle
di larici dei primi abeti che saranno
riusciti a tornare grazie ai semi
trasportati dal vento o alle piccole
piantine che già oggi nel silenzio
sporgono la loro testa al di sotto dei
tronchi abbattuti vedete non sarebbe la
prima volta che gli alberi ci
sorprendono con la loro capacità di
ritornare dopo un disastro se non siamo
noi a distruggerle
le foreste hanno una capacità
incredibile di reagire a questo tipo di
eventi come nel parco di yellowstone
1988 un grande incendio distrugge un
terzo delle foreste del parco ci si
preoccupa per il futuro di tutta la
vegetazione dell'ecosistema intero
eppure le pigne di quella foresta che
erano coperte da una resina durissima
che si poteva sciogliere solo se un
calore della fiamma le toccava ecco che
l'incendio fece aprire tutte le pigne
che erano disperse al suolo milioni di
semi si sparsero nell'ambiente
e furono in grado di germinare già
l'anno successivo vedete è nel dna delle
piante la capacità di resistere ai
disturbi alle catastrofi naturali o di
ritornare dopo che sono avvenuti proprio
nel dna letteralmente 500 milioni di
anni di evoluzione hanno impresso nel
genoma degli alberi la capacità di saper
reagire ai problemi con una fantasia
immensa il cipresso calvo della
louisiana per esempio la sua base è
allargata a forma di campana perché per
resistere agli uragani e non far
schiantare l'albero sotto i loro forti
venti le sue radici sono capaci di
crescere nell'aria per continuare
approvvigionare di ossigeno le cellule e
quindi farle sopravvivere anche quando
le ondate di marea sommergono la foresta
sotto due o tre metri di acqua salmastra
la palma da cocco sembra il più statico
di tutti gli alberi con questo seme
enorme che non sarebbe capace di
spostarsi se non per qualche centimetro
dalla pianta madre
eppure quando la noce di cocco cade
sulla sabbia e viene catturata dal mare
in tempesta è in grado di galleggiare e
portare in salvo l'embrione per mesi un
sistema di trasporto così efficace che
ancora oggi i botanici non sanno
spiegarsi quale sia il luogo d'origine
vero di questa specie il pino cembro
delle nostre montagne ha imparato
addirittura a stringere un patto col
diavolo i suoi semi sono il cibo
preferito della nocciolaia che li
nasconde nel terreno per poterli
consumare con calma durante l'inverno
ogni tanto però la nocciolaia si
dimentica di un nascondiglio oppure non
lo usa più non ce n'è più bisogno
ed ecco che da quei semi e solo da lì
nascono i nuovi pini in quella che gli
studiosi chiamano coevoluzione cioè
evoluzione collaborativa tra la pianta e
l'uccello e guardate che crescere in
gruppo in montagna può fare la
differenza
alberi che crescono insieme si possono
proteggere dal freddo dalla neve e dai
venti ghiacciati riuscendo a
sopravvivere lì dove è un individuo
isolato risulterebbe impossibile e non
ci sono solo gli uccelli i funghi
stabiliscono relazioni strettissime con
gli alberi attaccandosi alle loro radice
radici aumentando la loro superficie di
assorbimento in cambio al fungo è
permesso di succhiare un pochino delle
sostanze nutritive che la radice produce
così il fungo si alimenta aumenta le sue
dimensioni fino a costruire una vera e
propria rete di collegamento tra piante
pianta da cui passano sostanze nutritive
segnali chimici è una forma di
comunicazione che i ricercatori hanno
appena incominciato a decifrare questa
ad esempio la strategia che permette ad
alcuni alberi di fare un pò gli
alpinisti e di salire a quota e dove i
suoli sassosi renderebbero altrimenti
impossibile sopravvivere con le loro
sole sole radici in tutto il mondo altri
line limite a cui arrivano gli alberi si
sono trovati i segni delle micorrize di
queste simbiosi tra fungo e piante e
quasi tutte le tre line del mondo stanno
salendo di quota lentamente come
risultato dell'aumento delle temperature
oppure del cambiamento che l'uomo ha
attraversato nel modo di usare il
territorio per esempio abbandonando i
pascoli e rendendoli disponibili al
ritorno della foresta
un fenomeno questo del ritorno della
foresta che in europa sta procedendo
grande velocità contrariamente ad altre
parti nel mondo le foreste in europa in
italia stanno aumentando da noi 30.000
ettari di nuovi boschi ogni anno
un'opportunità straordinaria soprattutto
per quanto riguarda l'assorbimento del
carbonio nei tronchi oppure nel loro
legno se riusciremo ad aiutare questi
boschi a sopportare i nuovi climi che
verranno
ma un'opportunità che sembriamo un po
ignorare non solo perché la maggior
parte di noi non sa bene che l'italia è
un paese di foreste ma anche perché la
grande quantità di legno che noi per
fortuna utilizziamo viene ancora in gran
parte dall'estero e molti casi viene
ricavata in modo illegale o
insostenibile così mentre le foreste a
casa nostra si espandono ci rendiamo
corresponsabili della distruzione di
foreste dall'altra parte del mondo con
una grave minaccia per la loro
biodiversità e per la nostra
l'udienza climatica una minaccia che
dobbiamo assolutamente scongiurare
cambiando i modi di produzione e di
consumo che sono responsabili di questo
meccanismo a partire dal tipo di legno
che utilizziamo fino al tipo di cibo che
mettiamo nei nostri piatti
vedete l'evoluzione in realtà non c'è
equipaggiati con la capacità di capire
subito le conseguenze delle nostre
azioni a migliaia di chilometri di
distanza eppure dobbiamo imparare a
farlo se non lo faremo
rischieremo di renderci responsabili di
una estinzione di massa la sesta a
colpire la terra dopo il meteorite che
sterminò i dinosauri 65 milioni di anni
fa
secondo lei pbs la massima autorità
dell'onu che si occupa di biodiversità
un milione di specie oggi sono a rischio
di estinzione
la metà di quelle che conosciamo il 40
per cento degli anfibi un terzo dei
mammiferi marini e dei coralli il 10 per
cento degli insetti
la loro scomparsa ci riguarderebbe molto
da vicino un ecosistema con meno specie
infatti è meno stabile meno ospitale ed
è molto più vulnerabile agli estremi dei
cambiamenti climatici
eppure basterebbe rallentare se
abbassassimo un po le nostre pretese ci
accorgeremmo che le foreste che ci
circondano già ci possono dare molto di
quello di cui abbiamo bisogno e guardate
che non parlo solo del legno ma anche
dello straordinario potere degli alberi
di rendere resilienti gli uomini che ci
abitano vicino le foreste di montagna se
gestite con cura hanno il potere di
bloccare i massi che rotolano lungo un
pendio con i loro tronchi facendo da
barriera le loro radici trattengono il
terreno impedendogli di franare
scivolare verso valle
così gli abitanti delle montagne o i
milioni di turisti delle città possono
godere in pace e in sicurezza di questi
territori
magari senza sapere che devono
ringraziare una foresta per questo
privilegio
nelle città gli alberi abbassano la
temperatura assorbono la pioggia con le
loro foglie garantendoci di tollerare
meglio le sempre più frequenti ondate di
calore
dell'estate e di sopportare gli effetti
dei nubifragi sempre più intensi e
improvvisi facendo così una formidabile
alleato nella nostra capacità di
adattamento ai cambiamenti climatici
basta guardare riconoscere saper vedere
i fili invisibili che ci legano alle
foreste sapere quello che loro fanno per
noi e dargli valore e importanza come
l'hai al island nel giugno del 1985
quella protesta non violenta
fu l'inizio di una rinascita quindici
anni dopo aida ottennero l'inedito
privilegio dal governo canadese
dico amministrare tutte le loro risorse
naturali dagli oceani e alle foreste
oggi le foreste delle haida gwaii non
vengono più distrutte sono ancora
gestite anche per produrre legno ma ogni
decisione passa dagli aida e dalla
comunità che si interroga su quale sia
il bene delle isole e dei loro abitanti
umani e non umani la lingua aida era
ormai una lingua quasi morta parlata da
poche decine di persone
ebbene oggi è insegnata e utilizzata in
tutte le isole a partire dal loro nome
ufficiale sulle carte geografiche che è
stato cambiato dalla lingua inglese
queen charlotte island alla lingua
nativa haida gwaii isole del popolo alla
corte suprema del canada e in corso un
processo storico aida hanno richiesto la
totale indipendenza
basandosi su l'unica prova documentata
della loro presenza continuata sulle
isole
3 molti millenni prima dell'arrivo degli
europei una prova visibile a tutti i
resti delle canoe mezze lavorate nei
tronchi millenari sparsi nella foresta
nel 2013 a lisle island venne eretto un
totem il primo dopo 150 anni
alla base era scolpito un salmone in
cima un'aquila il rapporto col mare
il rapporto con la foresta la
costituzione della nazione aida si apre
con queste parole la nostra cultura si
fonda sul rispetto e l'intimità con il
mare la terra e l'area intorno a noi
come in una foresta le nostre radici
sono così profondamente intrecciate che
gli eventi più sfavorevoli non potranno
sopraffarci grazie
[Applauso]